bonjour je suis marie dosée je suis
avocate pénaliste et j'ai accepté de
réagir aux archives de Lina
[Musique]
bonjour Marie-Josée bonjour on va
parcourir ensemble les archives de Lina
alors on va commencer avec votre
première télé vous avez 29 ans vous
exercez depuis seulement deux ans et
pourtant vous avez un aplomb incroyable
face au procureur de Paris le coupable
me révolte parce que j'ai pas prêté
serment il y a 3 ans pour ça j'ai prêté
serment pour défendre les gens j'ai pas
prêté serment pour demander l'indulgence
à mon adversaire qu'il parquet et je ne
comprends pas très bien dans cette
logique où on nous assène depuis
plusieurs mois que la seule façon de
lutter contre la délinquance et
d'imposer des valeurs républicaines on
va amener imprévenu à négocier sa peine
je comprends pas ça j'ai besoin d'une
justice avec un J majuscule j'ai pas
besoin de négociation
oui j'avais complètement oublié en ma
qualité d'avocat oui c'était ma première
télévision et je crois que je n'avais
pas tout à fait conscience de ceux qui
m'entouraient je pense c'était pas une
forme de naïveté mais j'étais vraiment
tellement contre ce qui était en train
de se passer que je me concentrais sur
cela mais je me moquais un peu des
interlocuteurs en tout cas c'est pas eux
qui me faisait peur oui c'est vrai alors
on va maintenant évoquer une cause que
vous défendez contre certains politiques
justement on parle du rapatriement des
enfants et des femmes de djihadistes
bonjour
vous avez combien d'enfants
elle dit avoir 25 ans
d'ici quelques heures s'il vous plaît la
caméra elle sera interrogée par les
services de renseignement américain et
français puis transféré dans un camp
avec ses deux fillettes si on m'avait
dit il y a 20 ans
21 ans 22 ans maintenant si on m'avait
dit que j'allais passer trois ans quatre
ans cinq ans à multiplier les procédures
pour obtenir le rapatriement d'enfants
qui tousse au moment où il rentre dans
ces camps en moins de 6 ans dans leur
pays c'est-à-dire la France pays des
droits de l'homme je l'aurais pas cru
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous considérez que
le gouvernement fait son devoir non il
n'a pas fini de le faire en tout cas il
a commencé à le faire mais il a attendu
4 ans 5 ans pour le faire et il se
trouve 4 que 4 années 5 années c'est le
temps de l'enfance et ça va être très
compliqué d'expliquer à ses gamins qui
ont ils auront 15 ans 16 ans que la
France a préféré les voir périr souffrir
agonir dans des camps sordides plutôt
que de les voir rentrer c'est tout ça la
difficulté la France a attendu d'être
condamnée par le Comité des droits de
l'enfant par la Cour européenne par le
Comité contre la torture des Nations
Unies pour enfin évoluer dans sa
doctrine et très sincèrement moi je ne
pensais pas une seconde
que notre pays en était arrivé là tout à
l'heure dans ce que vous avez montré
vous avez appelé ces enfants Les enfants
de djihadiste je peux plus entendre ça
on n'a pas appelé les enfants des
collaborateurs entre 42-45 les enfants
de collabo et puis surtout ce sont pas
des enfants de jazz d'abord ce sont des
enfants et s'il faut les appeler
appelons les enfants des camps ces
enfants sont rentrés dans les camps les
deux tiers avaient entre deux et trois
ans certains ils sont nés tous les
autres avaient moins de 6 ans leur
souvenir de la Syrie ce sont les camps
c'est pas daesh et les camps c'est
l'histoire d'une France qui les laisse
là-bas et qui refusent de les rapatrier
je pense qu'à un moment donné il faut
faire oeuvre de pédagogie et moi j'ai
fait œuvre de pédagogie pendant quatre
ou cinq ans il y a 5 ans quand je
parlais de ce sujet on recevait au
cabinet 10 menaces de mort par jour
aujourd'hui je reçois 10 à 15 demandes
de stage
pourquoi parce que je ne sais pas ce
qu'est l'opinion publique mais en tout
cas une certaine Fage de la société est
révolté a évolué considère que ce qui
est en train de se faire ne sert qu'à
fabriquer de la défiance et le
terrorisme de demain alors on va vous
montrer maintenant une archive
exceptionnelle qu'il s'agit du premier
procès filmé en France ça se passe en
1987 et c'était sur Antenne 2 voici
posséder de ses gardes
clos
il faisait régner la terreur
aujourd'hui la justice lui demande des
cons veuillez vous asseoir monsieur
alors c'est un peu compliqué pour moi
cette image parce que je dois avoir 12
ou 13 ans je m'en souviens très bien et
j'ai laissé échapper
en regardant cette image celle-là tout
particulièrement celle là j'ai laissé
échapper un une mine ou je ne sais pas
où ou un son de désolation et de pitié
et je me souviens de la réaction de mon
père qui a été furieux
et c'est vrai que j'ai vu cette image
d'un grand-père j'étais très attaché à
mon grand-père et j'ai vu un grand-père
me noter qu'avait et vraiment mon père
était très en colère et en tout cas ces
images terribles des camps mon père me
les a montré à ce moment-là en réponse à
ma réaction ça n'a pas guéri mon premier
réflexe de pitié aujourd'hui je n'ai
aucune pitié pour que Klaus Barbie qui a
été jugé j'ai pas de difficulté je dis
juste je veux juste qu'on expliquer ce
qu'une gamine de 12 ans peut comprendre
d'une image quand elle quand elle n'a
pas l'outil historique juridique et
politique de ce qui se passe
opposer une violence à une autre
violence ça fonctionne pas en fait donc
j'ai été évidemment
broyée par les images des camps qui
m'ont toujours poursuivi qui me
poursuivent encore et qui poursuivent
tous ceux qui ont pu les visionner parce
qu'on s'en remet pas mais la gamine que
j'étais ne comprenait pas que ces images
là
allez
m'aider non pas à supporter mais presque
à me réjouir
d'un homme vieux menotté
et ça c'était compliqué pour moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à comprendre ce que cet
exercice pédagogique est censé amener
vous défendez le droit à l'oubli pour
les personnes qui ont purgé leur peine
quand il s'agit de personnalité
médiatiques le sujet peut être explosif
à chaque concert à chaque ville où il
est programmé Bertrand Cantat suscite la
polémique à Grenoble l'artiste doit se
produire à la belle électrique les 13 et
14 mars prochain un choix qui n'est pas
du goût de tous on aimerait que le maire
de notre ville dise que
il désapprouve d'autres mères l'ont fait
que lui-même bien sûr évidemment n'ira
pas ce concert
condamné en 2004 pour le meurtre de sa
compagne Marie Trintignant et libérée en
2007 l'ex chanteur de Noir Désir étant
tourné actuellement un choix de
programmation artistique uniquement
artistique explique la salle de concert
grenobloise
nous sommes dans une société où chacun
est libre de faire ce qu'il veut moi je
ne vous dis pas que j'ai envie d'aller
voir Bertrand Cantat au concert je ne
vous dis pas que j'ai envie d'aller le
voir au théâtre on est allé quand même
jusqu'à jeter la peinture rouge sur des
gens qui allaient voir cet artiste en
hurlant le son de Marie au prétexte
qu'il devenait les complices du crime
pour lequel Bertrand Cantat avait purgé
sa peine c'est ça moi qui qui me gêne le
plus en réalité la peine elle a été
purgée si on veut parler de bannissement
prononçons les mots nous souhaitons
après l'exécution d'une peine pénale
qu'un artiste soit banni et qu'il soit
interdit de chanter de jouer qu'il
n'existe plus nous souhaitons sa mort
sociale ou en tout cas sa mort
artistique mais ça nous ramène en étant
très très peu rassurant tout ça moi je
défends pas le droit l'oubli le mal qui
a été fait il s'oublie pas
j'en sais quelque chose je défends pas
que des accusés vous savez je défends
beaucoup de victimes beaucoup de parties
civiles et je leur dis vous l'oublierez
jamais ce qui a été fait vous ne
l'oublierez pas mais on va essayer de le
ranger quelque part pour que ça se
réveille le moins possible on va vous
montrer maintenant historique qui a
passionné la France et qui vous a
passionné vous aussi depuis le 16
octobre 1984 cette belle et humide des
Vosges et le théâtre du énigme qui a tué
le petit Grégory les lettres d'un
corbeau mènent tout d'abord les
enquêteurs vers le cousin de Jean-Marie
Villemin Bernard Laroche est écroué
après le témoignage accablant de sa
belle-sœur
Villemin Laroche les journalistes se
passionnent pour cette guerre des clans
premier d'une longue série de
rebondissements la belle sorte de
Bernard Laroche se rétracte il y a un
jardin qui a levé la voix et puis j'ai
eu peur
montrer du doigt le juge Lambert accusé
de ne privilégier qu'une seule thèse et
les gendarmes trop proche de la presse
on en est exactement au même point qu'à
midi et que hier il y a deux jours
malheureusement et si jamais vous pouvez
nous aider ça sera bien accueilli l'aide
des journalistes aura des effets
désastreux sur l'enquête à la libération
de Bernard Laroche les soupçons du juge
glissent vers Christine Villemin mais
pour son mari il n'y a aucun doute
il faudra 8 ans à la justice pour
finalement innocenter la mère de Grégory
et reconnaître entre autres erreurs son
impuissance à trouver la vérité
Jean-Marie Villemin lui a purgé sa peine
de 34 mois de détention
à quelle fiasco quel honte quelle honte
médiatique
judiciaire société
je suis en Lorraine là je suis petite et
l'Est Républicain ne parlait que de ça
mais que de ça moi j'ai le souvenir mais
de toutes ces images de toutes ces une
de Grégory Villemin on en parlait à
l'école mais c'est pour vous dire
j'étais persuadée moi que c'était mon
oncle qu'il avait tué
Grégory demain parce qu'il ressemblait
beaucoup au portrait-robot qui ressemble
à Bernard Laroche que mon oncle au
Luxembourg j'avais ouvert le tiroir
j'avais vu un pistolet on est tous les
gamins tous les gamins étaient à la fois
fascinés par cette faits divers et ne
parlait que de ça et puis après avant de
devenir avocate j'ai lu le merveilleux
livre de Laurence Lacourt qui m'a fait
très très peur et puis ensuite quand je
suis devenu avocate j'ai compris à quel
point cette affaire avait été un fiasco
mais d'une indemnité cras
et encore une fois sur le rôle des
journalistes sur les magistrats qui ont
été en dessous de tout mais jusqu'à
l'écrivaine que je chéris et que j'adore
Duras
tout y est passé quoi vraiment il n'y a
absolument rien à sauver dans cette
affaire vous m'aidez vous passez
beaucoup de temps dans les prises on a
trouvé beaucoup de reportages qui
dénonçaient leurs conditions de vie et
on en a trouvé un intéressant en 1980 où
la télévision nous montrait un autre
visage des prisons françaises changement
de décor et d'ambiance c'est
certainement l'illustration la plus
frappante de l'évolution des prisons
parce qu'il y a des choses que vous
appréciez ici par rapport à l'ancienne
détention oui
[Musique]
ici on a l'eau chaude on a la radio en
cellule dans les prisons rénovées les
détenus disposent d'un petit studio
qu'ils peuvent aménager à leur guise ce
confort relatif risque de choquer encore
beaucoup de monde
les détenus en tout cas s'ils sont vite
habitués car pour eux ça n'est pas
l'essentiel
quand je suis arrivé ici dans cette
nouvelle prison j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé
le paradis en arrivant parce que j'ai
trouvé de la propreté l'hygiène
à l'extérieur appellent une prison de
luxe
moi je vais en prison plusieurs fois par
semaine et je n'ai jamais réussi à m'y
habituer les 22 ans que je réussis pas à
habituer j'aurais réussi pas m'habituer
à marcher
en faisant claquer mes talons de bottes
pour pour être sûr que le rat ne soit
pas au Parlement avocat de la maison
d'arrêt de Fresnes je m'habitue pas à
avoir tous ces cafards à rencontrer ces
détenus qui se grattent j'ai attrapé la
gale moi oui
un détention sans avoir été incarcéré
rien qu'en passant du temps avec ce que
je défends j'ai attrapé la gale bon la
peine
c'est une privation de liberté c'est pas
une violence d'État c'est pas faire
souffrir c'est pas humilié c'est pas un
traitement inhumain et dégradant c'est
une privation de liberté les gens sont
condamnés à 15 ans 20 ans 5 ans
d'emprisonnement mais pas
d'emprisonnement dans cet enfer là parce
qu'en plus si la réponse à la violence
elle est la violence d'État on s'en
sortira jamais regardez le taux de
récidive en France et comparer le à ceux
qui ont fait le choix de prison
intelligente on est malade en France par
exemple de la détention provisoire on
est malade de la détention provisoire
c'est une maladie nationale près d'un
tiers des personnes aujourd'hui
incarcérées sont présumés innocents ne
sont pas jugés maintenant un homme qui
s'est beaucoup battu l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des détenus mais dans
cet archive de 1981 il parle d'un autre
sujet la perception du métier d'avocat
je sens une hostilité que nous voyons
tous les jours
lequel d'entre nous n'a pas subi des
injures lequel d'entre nous n'a pas été
agressé soit par téléphone soit dans la
rue par des gens qui lui reprochaient de
défendre tel ou tel parce que un certain
niveau les gens n'acceptent pas la
défense
et ce refus de la défense c'est en fait
un refus de la justice
et là nous dépassons même le cadre
politique là où il n'y a pas de défense
là où il n'y a pas d'avocat il n'y a pas
de juge oui Henri Leclerc pour moi c'est
il reprend énormément de choses d'abord
c'est la première personne que j'ai vu
plaider
à Nancy
je savais pas qu'il était
j'ai vraiment une sentiment en écoutant
de
de d'écouter un concerto et je me suis
disais ça que je fais et puis ensuite
quand je suis allée à Paris j'ai
travaillé dans son cabinet pendant
quelques mois le temps de ce qu'on
appelait le stage les élèves avocats
et c'est quelqu'un que que je n'ai
jamais quitté j'ai un immense respect
pour lui et
au-delà de l'admiration j'ai aussi une
vraie affection et sur les propos de
d'Henri Leclerc est-ce que il faut
déplaire pour être avocat est-ce que
c'est un exercice solitaire alors c'est
un
exercice au combien et tant mieux
effectivement que c'est un rapport entre
soi et soi et entre soi et les autres
mais c'est quelque chose de très
personnel qu'on construit donc lui c'est
un exercice très solitaire et
déplaire oui évidemment si vous avez
besoin d'être aimé faut surtout pas
devenir avocat
même si vous avez besoin d'être aimé par
vos clients il faut aimer défendre mais
si vous avez vraiment besoin dans votre
quotidien de vous sentir aimé admiré il
faut faire tout sauf avocat pénaliste
c'est pas dû c'est pas du tout là qu'il
faut qu'il faut se ranger ou s'atteler à
grandir vous vous destiniez peut-être à
une autre carrière pour parler de votre
passé on va regarder une plutôt écoutée
le RTF en 1969
allez voir ainsi sagement assise coup de
scout on pourrait bien les prendre pour
ce qu'elles sont deux jeunes filles de
bonne famille distillant Schubert à
quatre mains
cela pourrait être seulement cela or
c'est autre chose aussi car Katia et
Marielle labecque c'est la même que
leurs amis appellent affectueusement les
petites la becs ne sont pas des
velléitaires et il y a longtemps déjà
qu'elles ont choisi de vivre par la
musique et pour la musique ensemble lui
sacrifiant tout ce qui fait pour les
autres une jeunesse insouciante
ah oui alors ouais ça faisait longtemps
que je les avais pas vu j'étais
tellement admiratrice de ces deux sœurs
en plus j'ai une sœur jumelle donc
forcément ok pas du tout pianiste mais
et ouais alors je m'identifie à l'une et
à l'autre dans mes rêves de petite fille
et mes parents m'ont emmené les voir à
Bar-le-Duc je m'en souviens encore et la
réalité c'est que je les ai pas vu parce
que j'étais trop petite je crois alors
soit j'étais face à un poteau soit face
à quelqu'un de très grand je ne sais
plus mais je me souviens on est très
gentil mais c'est ça va ma pauvre ça va
tu parles en concert et
rien de savoir que c'était elle qui
jouait mais je les ai pas vu même pas
leurs cheveux nous sourions mais de
savoir que c'était elle qui jouait
c'était c'était merveilleux et qu'est-ce
qui vous a empêché d'être de devenir
pianiste je suis tombée malade j'ai une
maladie des mains qui est génétique et
qui heureusement s'est déclaré à ce
moment-là parce que si elle s'était
déclarée 30 ans plus tard j'aurais été
bien embêté et donc voilà j'ai donc du
tout arrêter et je me suis souviens
d'avoir d'avoir pensé bon très bien quel
est le contraire de la musique puisque
la maladie choisit à ma place c'est bien
par défi je vais choisir le contraire de
la musique et je me suis dit c'est la
faculté de droit et sur ça je voudrais
juste dire une chose j'ai toujours été
stupéfaite par ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui parcoursup parce que moi
voyez-vous je si ça s'appliquait si ça
s'était appliqué à moi j'aurais jamais
été reçu dans aucune faculté de droit de
France parce qu'après un bac musique et
une année de conservatoire est prof en
école municipal aucune faculté de droit
n'aurait accepté que j'intègre la
première année quoi et je trouve ça
compliqué de resserrer les destins à
l'heure aux personnes ne sait qui il est
c'est l'heure de conclure l'émission
mais avant de se quitter on va vous
montrer quatre visages on va vous
demander de choisir celui qui va vous
poser une question entre Jacques Chancel
Henri Chapier Denise Glaser et Caroline
Tresca
je peux pas choisir quelqu'un d'autre
que Jacques Chancel Jacques Chancel
berce tous mes étés c'est à dire que je
réécoute
toutes les émissions de Jacques Chancel
à la radio avec
toutes celles et ceux qui l'a
interviewé en marchant
donc c'est évidemment lui tous les étés
et je fais ça depuis des années certains
coups vous ont fait mal alors nous
n'avons jamais vu une tracé évidente sur
votre visage de ses goûts reçus et de
vous insensible
alors ce qui me connaissent bien
voir
[Musique]
peut-être même un peu trop les traces
d'écho sur mon visage et
[Musique]
j'ai toujours souffert d'une trop grande
sensibilité
bon il paraît que c'est une richesse
merci beaucoup Marie dosée d'avoir
voyagé avec nous dans les archives de
Lina merci à vous merci beaucoup
[Musique]